kim cattrall is dishing about her
decision to not be a part of the sex in
the city reboot and just like that the
actress opens up to variety for their
special women of power issues saying she
knew the time had come to say goodbye to
samantha jones it's a great wisdom to
know when enough is enough cattrall
tells the magazine the actress reveals
she simply wasn't asked to be part of
the rebooted series admitting she found
out it was a go at the same time as
everyone else
i was never asked to be part of the
reboot i made my feelings clear after
the possible third movie so i found out
about it like everyone else did on
social media but i think especially at
this period of my life
is that a set i want to be on is that a
character i want to live with
while the relationship between catral
and former co-star sarah jessica parker
has long been discussed in public when
asked by variety about whether or not
she ever considered parker kristen davis
and cynthia nixon her friends she had
this to say
i guess it's how you define friends i
think we were colleagues my colleagues
aren't my friends it was professional
we're here to spend time together just
the four of us while it may have been
all business on set in an interview with
variety parker confirmed she would not
be okay with catrell reprising her role
as fan favorite samantha anyway which
was news took a trial i don't think i
read that the actress said before adding
it would never happen anyway so nobody
has to worry about that so nothing's
better when you say no as opposed to
someone else does while fans may be
holding out hope that one day samantha
jones may return catral has this to say
that's a no it's powerful to say no